Speaker 1: We have stumbled across another
possible major scam from the Donald Trump
administration.
It turns out that the Trump administration
gave a one point three billion dollar contract
to a company called Apage Act like inject,
but maybe it's even API jacked like a look
at a computer API they gave him.
He gave them a one point three dollars billion
contract to make covid vaccine syringes.
The U.S. has now given out about close to
200 million individual doses and there are
zero vaccine syringes from abject applejack
to API ject.
What the hell is going on?
We don't know.
NBC News reporting that a year after the company
was awarded and almost one point three billion
dollar contract and loan package to supply
syringes for rolling out the covid-19 vaccine,
zero syringes have been made.
The syringe hasn't even gotten the first approval
it needs from the FDA before it can be manufactured.
And the factory that was going to create six
hundred and fifty jobs to create this.
As yet, an approved vaccine has not even been
built.
One point three billion contracts and loans,
no factory, no approval, no syringes.
The company API JECT Systems Corporation said
it was going to be the company that would
make the difference between a bad rollout
and a good rollout of the coronavirus vaccines.
A thanks to the Biden administration, the
U.S. coronavirus vaccine rollout is going
really well.
About half of American adults have received
at least one dose.
We are close.
We are rapidly getting into the 30s and soon
40s in terms of the percentage of Americans
that have been fully vaccinated.
The need for this syringe from API ject is
now drastically diminished because we basically
have what we need.
And it seems as though we are going to have
everything we need to fully vaccinate the
United States.
And yet the contracts and the loans are still
there.
API JECT was contacted by NBC News.
They were asked what the hell is going on?
That was not how the question was asked.
That's how I would ask it.
They said that they are, quote, working with
several pharmaceutical companies to conduct
testing and reviews of the API ject syringe
for covid-19 vaccination.
What?
When is this going to happen?
It's going to be over before they make any
vaccine syringes.
A spokesperson from Pfizer said that even
if the syringe was approved by the FDA, it
would have no impact on the level of vaccine
output or on the process for distributing
vaccines by Pfizer.
Moderna was asked, what about you?
They didn't respond.
Johnson and Johnson declined to comment on
this.
What it's just listen, we don't yet know the
full scope of this.
There should be audits of every single one
of these contracts that the Trump administration
gave out.
If the recipients aren't at a stage in the
process that they should be or close to actually
being able to deliver what they were contracted
to do, the contracts, which I mean, they need
to be canceled.
The government should be asking for money
back should lawsuits be filed to try to recoup
the money that's already been paid, because
increasingly it seems that there is no economic
policy or contract or whatever it all during
the Trump administration seems to link to
mostly unsuccessful either outright failures
or incompetency or participating in grifting
by these companies.
There was another one we covered a few months
ago, and the details are just beyond my my
recollection.
But I think it was a PPE company that was
not even making the PPY, but it was like a
middle man of some kind that the Trump administration
gave a big contract to.
And they had like no employees.
They were a three month old.
It was just all grifting, grifting, grifting.
API spokesperson Steve Hoffman says when asked
about the factory, because, remember, this
was a contract and loans to do covid vaccine
syringes at a new factory that would generate
650 jobs.
The spokesperson for AP, Steve Hoffman, was
asked by NBC News, Where's the factory?
And he says that land has been cleared for
construction in North Carolina.
Asked when will the actual construction begin,
Steve Hoffman was not able to say.
It seems likely that the land is not good,
that the factory is not going to be built
in time for API to participate in syringe
production that will be materially relevant
to the covid vaccine distribution.
It was all agreed.
It was all a grift.
And it's almost every week we find out of
some Trump administration grift or Trump campaign
gift related to fundraising, related to contracts
related to positions for friends and family
of Donald Trump.
It just never stops.
I don't expect we will ever know the full
scope of it.
I'm hopeful that over time we will learn more
and more about it.
I don't think we are going to learn the full
scope.
Let me know what you believe should be done
with these types of contracts.
Should API have to return the money?
What exactly should happen or should we take
the approach of it's in the past, let's let
them get away with the one point three billion.
I tend to think the answer is no to that second
option.
Let me know what you think.
Speaker 1: We'll take a quick break.
I do want to follow up about what's in, you
know, the biggest beneficiary of the last
24 hours, 48 hours, 72 hours of coverage of
the Derek Chauvin case and other things.